[Music]
the main character of the tombs of
ottawa is arha and we see at the very
beginning of the novel that she is
consecrated
as a child
to the service of the nameless ones and
these are going to turn out to be
some of the old powers of the earth and
that's going to come through
ged one of the other major characters of
the novel telling her some important
things that allow a picture to be
filled in further there's actually a lot
of information being given
about the nameless ones we begin by
learning about a ritual that the
young girl goes through that sets her
apart she is supposed to be the
reincarnated
priestess who has you know generation
after generation after generation
died been reborn in another girl child
at the exact same moment
brought to the temple which is one of
the oldest places
in not just ottawa but the kargish isles
and civilization entirely and it's
because
of these old powers that she
is the servant
the in some respects the representative
and the caretaker
of and there's a lot of rituals involved
which we don't have to go into you can
read them in the book but
these nameless ones exist
we don't really know how long
did they ever have a beginning did they
emerge with the earth itself
in earth sea
their their
antiquity goes back too far for human
beings or perhaps even dragons to know
but they live in this case
at and under the tombs of ottawa so
they're they're localized they
don't have a lot of sway over what's
going to happen on other islands or even
quite so much in other parts of ottawa
yet early on
in the cargo civilization this became a
place where the nameless ones were
consulted
through a form of divination and the
priestess was an incredibly important
mediator
and the priestess herself in this case
arja is the current arja the current
eaten one her name as she gets at the
start and then gets back later on is
tenor but her name is eaten for a good
half of the novel and we also find out
that prisoners
who have done you know terrible things
in in the case of the three men who are
sent they tried to attack the god king
they're sent to ottowan for
punishment
by the priestess and she are
now as a
young woman takes some uh
agency in this
and
they're also viewed as being eaten by
the nameless ones because they die
in those tombs which would also apply to
the many different
heroes and thieves and mages that came
trying to seek the
lost half of the ring
of uh aerith akba right who are also
trapped underneath the
the tombs in the maze
and so eating is kind of a metaphor here
for what these ancient powers do
they are older and have precedence over
the other
cults of of the kargs
including the
twin brothers but also especially the
god kings who are kind of a johnny come
lately a new new kid on the block
religiously speaking and there's
actually an important confrontation that
is going to take place between the
priestess the high priestess of the
god king
and the
arha the the priestess of the
nameless ones and there's this
confrontation that takes place having to
do with the wizard uh who's there and
arja says
[Music]
my my masters will tell me
the rest does not concern you priestess
this time she'd gone too far others
could hear
kossil was aware of it all that happens
here is my concerned mistress all that
happens in his realm is the concern of
the god king the man immortal whose
servant i am even into the places
underground and into the hearts of men
does he search and look and none shall
forbid him entrance then arha says
i shall
into the tombs no one comes if the
nameless ones forbid it they were before
your god king and will be after him
speak softly of them priestess do not
call their vengeance on you they will
come into their your dreams they will
enter the dark places in your mind and
you will go mad the girl's eyes were
blazing costl's face was hidden drawn
into the black cowl
their old castle's voice said not loud a
whistling thread of sound under the
depths of the cowl they are old their
worship is forgotten save in this one
place their power is gone they are only
shadows they have no power anymore do
not try to frighten me eaten one you are
the first priestess that does that not
mean also that you are the last you
cannot trick me i see into your heart
the darkness hides nothing from me and
then arja says may the dark ones eat
your soul
castle she casts a curse on her and so
what we've got here is a conflict
between two different
religious cults and perhaps two
powers there's the god kings who are the
new
you know representative uniting the
kargish lands into an empire a very
visible power and then we have the
cothonian
gods or powers of the
earth who we don't see and we're not
quite sure if they have
power or not
what we do
have going on before that is that the
nameless ones
have their domain at the tombs and
underneath the tombs what we see
mentioned over and over again is not
just darkness
but their vengeance
their anger
their
wrath at sacrilege or
defiling that could happen their their
their area is supposed to be only for
the priestess what we find is that even
the other high priestesses say
we're not going to go into all of these
parts although castle herself as as
we've seen is a disbeliever and is
willing to commit sacrilege she lights
up the room that is never supposed to be
illuminated so that she can check
whether ged's grave not really his grave
is a true one containing his body
or not and ged himself will suggest that
the old powers have driven
castle mad a madness where she cannot
even recognize that they are dangerous
that transgression
will bring about their anger
and we learn a lot about these powers
actually so does arja she learns about
the very power she's dealing with
by her engagements with get
and this is uh this is quite important
what's what's happening here first she
think you know she sees him and she says
this guy is here to commit sacrilege the
word came slowly into arha's mind this
was a man
no man's foot must ever touch the soil
of the tombs the holy place yet he had
come here into the hollow place that was
the heart of the tombs he had made light
where light was forbidden where it had
never been since the world beg the
world's beginning
why did the nameless ones not strike him
down
her masters had eaten those three why
did they not eat this one what were they
waiting for
for their hands to act for their tongue
to speak
and
as it's going to turn out
her masters the nameless ones the old
powers of the earth
the only thing that's holding them back
is is ged's own magic
a little bit later on she's asking him
about the scars
on his face and
she says did did a dragon do that no not
a dragon
he says the scars were before i was a
dragon lord
i told you i had met with the dark
powers before in other places of the
earth
this on my face is the mark of one of
the kinship
of the nameless ones
but no longer nameless for i learned his
name in the end she says what do you
mean what name i cannot tell you that
and what we're talking about there is
the
shadow
from a wizard of earthsea that had
scarred up his dead's face and that he
named with his own name at the very end
of the novel bringing about a resolution
and a sort of reintegration
but he also
encountered one of the other old powers
of the earth not just a kinship with
them but one of the old powers in oskil
so that's not being talked about here
but that's part of the story
we also find out that the reason why
ged has not succumbed to these powers
why they haven't done anything to him is
that he is actually through his own
force and power
checking them holding them back
and
arha is actually
quite upset when he tells her that she
says
nothing matters the
cos castle the priestess of the god king
she was always cruel she kept trying to
make me kill you the way i killed those
others she defied the nameless ones and
mocked them i set a curse on her since
then i've been afraid of her because
it's true that menon said she doesn't
believe in the gods she wants them to be
forgotten and she'd kill me while i
slept
now i see her down there committing
sacrilege a light burning in the holy
place the dark the dark place the
nameless ones did nothing
they didn't kill her or drive her mad
they are old as she said they're dead
they're all gone i'm not a priestess
anymore and god says
oh
if it was so easy as that
i have been holding them back this
entire time
he goes on and he says
[Music]
every instant since i've set foot in the
cavern under the tombstones i have
striven to keep them still to keep them
unaware all my skills have gone to that
i have spent my strength on it i've
filled these tunnels with an endless net
of spells spells of sleep of stillness
of concealment yet they're still aware
of me
half aware
half sleeping half awake
and even so i am all but worn out
striving against them this is a most
terrible place
one man alone has no hope here did you
truly think them dead you know better in
your heart they do not die
so
they are very powerful indeed and
ironically
it's ged's intervention
that has made it possible for castle to
invade and to transgress without being
punished
get also tells us some very important
things tells tells tenor or arja this
about the
powers
he says
they are dark and undying they hate the
light the brief bright light of our
mortality they are immortal
right and he goes on and says they all
their power is to darken and destroy
they cannot leave this place they are
this place and it should be left to them
and he sketches out not only what they
will do to other you know beings like
human beings he sketches out what human
being's attitude
should be towards these old powers of
the earth
he just a little bit earlier said
they are not gods although they are
immortal they never were and they are
not worthy
of the worship of any human soul
they've never given you anything
tenar
and he and he goes on and says
they should not be denied nor forgotten
neither should they be worshipped
the earth is beautiful and bright and
kindly but that's not all the earth is
also terrible and dark and cruel the
rabbit shrieks dying in the green
meadows the mountains clench their hands
full of hidden fire there are sharks in
the sea and there is cruelty in men's
eyes
so you know
nature is both good and bounteous but
also sinister
and terrifying and terrible he goes on
and he says
where men worship these things and abase
themselves before them their evil breeds
their places are made in the world where
darkness gathers places given
over wholly to the ones we call nameless
the ancient and holy powers of the earth
before the light the powers of the dark
of ruin
and madness
these nameless ones
are not dead
they are they exist but they are not
your masters they never were
so he's revealing to her that her
priestess stature
and status and the entire narrative
is in a certain sense not a lie
but a
mistake
something that
would be better not to be and she's
finding this out for herself
they escape from the tombs and what we
end up seeing is the anger
of the ancient powers of the earth the
nameless ones
manifesting itself in a sort of
self-destructive
but also oriented against the human
being's action so she we we see this
she turned and saw they were across the
valley on a level now with the
tombstones the nine great monoliths that
stood or lay above the cavern of
diamonds and graves the stones that
stood were moving
one of them seemed to twitch and rise
taller than a shudder went through it
and it fell another fell smashing
crossways on the on the first and the
earth of the valley ripples and buckles
there's an earthquake taking place
she looks to get and says
you held it back you held back the
earthquake the anger of the dark so the
the ancient powers they
manifest that power in something that's
uh that's impotent to affect arha or
tenor and ged
what brings about the death of many of
the other people
in that area including castle herself
who's meddling around
in the throne room and underneath the
the earth so
what we get to see here is a very
important part
of the
let's call it the
mythology and the
magical powers
of earthsea things that are not human
and according to god shouldn't be
worshipped or perhaps even trafficked in
by human beings the
ancient
old powers of the earth
you